is there a more Hollywood fabricated
plastic tell me what I should say guy
than Gavin Newsom I mean I I just seems
so are you trying to get him in trouble
his podcast could get canceled tomorrow
my opinion don't say no Adam you're
wrong the good thing is like I said I'm
unemployed and uncancelable but I do
have personal uh friends who who have
connections to Gavin Newsom so I'd
rather not speak about you know they are
all frauds okay period end of story I
mean Joe Biden Donald Trump these people
are full of [ __ ] they lie about their
backgrounds they lie about what they're
gonna do and you know it's just it's
that's why my frustration level is on
such a place because you really like I
did grow up and thinking people want to
be the president because they wanted to
make the place better but it's a 100
million dollar job if you get that job
you know so why wouldn't you want to be
AOC who you know is was a waitress and
now she wants to write books and she
wants to do this and that's why you know
I like I got in trouble because everyone
thought I was this left-wing linger when
Cuomo sold that book long before his
sexual harassment thing I'm like how is
this even legal that you can be a
sitting [ __ ] governor and you write
five books for five million dollars like
how is this possible that we allow this
and then again I don't want to go left
or right but like Pelosi with these
trades like how is this possibly legal
that they can let these these
congressmen do insider trading when they
know what's going to happen before it
happens so yeah you know you know what's
the what's the crazy thing is
uh uh we were talking to
uh Kanye said when I talked to Tupac
Tupac told me first go get your money
and then wreak havoc or whatever some
line like that that he talked about
Tupac told him this 20 some years ago 30
years ago in 1996 whatever the timeline
is Right years ago and
sometimes when you don't have a few
money you have to walk on eggshells
especially in your world yeah when you
don't have it yet uh and and you know
when you do you feel Freer you can say
whatever you want to say and I fully
understand that business model and but
sometimes people in your world are held
hostage yeah uh because of that and you
have to be part of the team because God
forbid you don't support it's going to
hurt your business and uh you one of the
things I'm most excited about Hollywood
what's happened the last I don't know 10
years is that the netflixes of the world
have come out the Hulu's of the world
these Otts are coming out where you no
longer need a Weinstein to you know do
something with them because he's got all
this power you no longer have to go
through gift and you don't no longer
have to go through yeah all of these
guys that at one point oh my gosh God
forbid I better please don't say this I
won't say it again I'm so sorry man you
know I'm you do this I'm not going to
give you this movie it's like oh my God
I'm never going to get a part again in
Hollywood my career is over with the
best part this those guys are gone and
today they're not gone but those guys
are not as powerful as they were before
and today a money person can come in and
say Doug
I don't give a [ __ ] which side you're on
politically here's 20 million bucks
let's go make a bunch of [ __ ] and we're
gonna put it on our Ott yeah and this is
what we're gonna do the freedom of these
Otts coming out now how has that shifted
your mindset within your industry what
we're really gonna see because I I just
went out and financed my own show you
know and you still need you still have
those Gatekeepers because you still need
the distribution if you want to go big I
think where the world will be in three
years you know like comedians I don't
know if you guys ever had what Andrew
Schultz or Dave Schultz I don't know you
know he released his own album Taylor
Swift goes and makes you know goes and
makes I know she's got 400 million
people following her but she goes and
makes her album in her own home she
doesn't need anybody so we did that with
a with a pilot
um so now we'll see what happens we just
finished it now we gotta shop it around
if we somehow can't get distribution
from one of the major platforms and we
will figure out a way that we will
release it ourselves so
um so that was really really exciting to
me because the process that I did this
pilot in you know where Entourage took
you know when when I talk about how Ari
sold that in the room I was paid fifty
thousand dollars to write a script that
took two years and torture and almost
almost to the point where if you really
wanted to like break it down it was far
less than minimum wage
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]